ننوه بهذا الخبر الذي يظهر على الشاشه
نقلا عن القناه الثال عش
الاسرائيليه ان جنودا مصابين في معارك غزه
رفضوا زياره نتنياهو لهم في مستشفى
هداس لمزيد من التفصيل حول هذا الخبر الذي
نقلته القناه الثالثه عش الاسرائيليه ينضم
الينا من تل ابيب مراسلنا الياس كرام
الياس اذا هذا تطور لافت ويعني واضح
انه رساله قويه يوجه هؤلاء الجنود
لنتنياهو
والمهم فيها لله هي انها ليست المره
الاولى التي يرفض فيها جنود مصابون من
معارك قطاع غزه لقاء بنيامين نتنياهو
عندما جاء لعيادته في المستشفى سبق وان
قام جنود اسرائيليون بهذه الخطوه عندما
اقد قدم بنيامين نتنياهو الى مستشفى شيبا
في تله شومير شرق تلي ابيب لعياده بعض
الجنود ورفض كثيرون منهم لقائه واضطرت
اداره المستشفى الى تجميع الجنود الذين
قبلوا بهذه الزياره في جناح واحد
لاستقباله وهذا كما يبدو حصل هذا اليوم
ايضا عندما قدم بنيامين نتنياهو الى
مستشفى هداس تحديدا الى قسم اعاده تاهيل
الجنود لزياره الجنود المصابين ويبدو ان
عددا كبيرا منهم رفضوا لقائه وهذه بطبيعه
الحال خطوه احتجاجيه من جانبهم على سياسه
هذه الحكومه ربما وربما على اخفاقاته سواء
كان ذلك في السابع من اكتوبر او ما تلى
ذلك من عمليات ومن قرارات اتخذتها الحكومه
الاسرائيليه احد الجنود الاسرائيليين
الذين كانوا في هذا القسم قال بان من بين
18 جنديا كانوا في ايه القسم 15 منهم
رفضوا لقاء بنيامين نتنياهو القناه
اي احضرت ايضا ردا من جانب احد المسؤولين
في المستشفى الذي قال بان قبول 10 ب من
اصل 20 بزياره بنيامين نتنياهو هذا امر
محترم لكن واضح بان هنالك حاله من
الاحتجاج وحاله من الغضب في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي وبطبيعه الحال الجنود
الاسرائيليون هم جزء لا يتجزا من هذا
المجتمع الاسرائيلي الغاضب على هذه
الحكومه وهذا بطبيعه الحال ليلى ما تترجمه
ايضا استطلاعات الراي سواء تلك المتعلقه
بانخفاض شعبيه بنيامين نتنياهو الى 30%
مقابل ارتفاع شعبيه عضو مجلس الحرب بين
جانس الى 51% في المجتمع الاسرائيلي وكنا
نذكر ليى فقط بعجاله كيف ان وزراء كثر في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه في ايام الحرب الاولى
كانوا يطردون من المستشفيات من قبل
المدنيين ومن قبل الجنود الذين اصيبوا في
تلك الايام y